[Music]
only in my dreams
[Music]
she is a singer-songwriter Pianist
record producer actress and now she can
add celebrity renovator to the list we
are thrilled to welcome Debbie Gibson to
the show thank you I'm not quite
quitting my day job I don't think that's
going on the resume but it was fun as a
one-off oh my goodness what a great
concept first of all welcome thank you a
lot of people know this but you are a
Las Vegas local I'm a local I you know I
don't leave my house a lot when I'm here
funny enough so people don't know I live
here like I'm not hitting all the red
carpets but I love it here it's been
more about a decade yeah what made you
decide to make this long island or this
Brooklyn I'm sorry girl well Brooklyn
Long Island the Manhattan yeah New
Yorker the New Yorker Las Vegas you know
I was in LA for a decade and then I was
back and forth here a lot and it was
like you know this is actually a great
place to live I love New York I love LA
but this it's like here it's not Showbiz
all the time it's like you can get that
on a strip if you want it but you can
kind of retreat back into your
neighborhood and it's just you know I I
love sunshine I love nature I love
people the people are super down home
and awesome and yeah I love everything
about it it's so great if you follow
Debbie on Instagram you can literally
see her taking out her trash cans in her
high heels yeah my neighbors just kind
of roll their eyes at me at this point
they're like there she goes again you
know but I'm waiting to do like a flash
mob like I want like all my neighbors to
do their trash cans at the same time on
week I have to choreograph it oh I love
it I love it now you're doing this new
show on CBS Friday night you can check
it out here eight o'clock celebrity
renovation tell us a little bit about
this show and and what you're doing on
it so my friend Michelle Turner
approached me about it and it's a way to
like say a big thank you to somebody who
has been super generous
um and my manager Heather she's like a
sister she helped me through
all of my health challenges she has
stuck with me in my career and also we
honor my mom who I lost earlier this
year because my mom really kind of
discovered Heather and kind of spotted
her Talent decades ago and then in a
twist of fate Heather ended up taking
over the management wow spot that my mom
had for so long and so it's it's really
a moving tribute to important people in
my life and uh yeah we renovate
Heather's home listen me with a
sledgehammer I love it is something to
behold we actually have a call from the
show let's take a look at that clip
this is my room
oh my God this is so crazy there would
always be kids on the weekend honking
their horns and blasting my music and
yelling we love you Debbie Gibson I ran
out that window and I'd be like peering
out who gets to have that experience I
don't know of many people who do yeah
they took me back to my my hometown and
my childhood house which I haven't been
in since I left in 1988. are we gonna
cry when we watch you are going to cry
there it was like this is your life and
it was they connect so many dots in this
show because you're honoring someone
you're you're repaying somebody but but
you're kind of reliving your own Youth
and it's it's so many things it's all
the feels on the show I cannot wait to
watch that that is again right here on
CBS Friday night another thing that I
mean you are you have so much going on
right now so much a lot of plates girl a
lot of places we're talking records and
someone I believe has a holiday record I
do I have my first ever holiday record
coming out uh in October and it's what
my two favorite Joey's On It Joey
McIntyre and Joe Gibson my dad who you
had the pleasure of here hearing thing
in my living room and I got him to
record on the album hearing you two
together was amazing and now everyone
gets to everyone gets to hear it and
Joey McIntyre and I wrote an original
that we you know uh do it on and we were
here last year at the Venetian doing
shows together so that's another kind of
Full Circle magical thing for me that
was quite the residency that you guys
did I'm curious if maybe another
residency is coming up I hope so I'll
send Joe I'm sending you this clip so
you see how many people ask me this
every day we we we have some projects up
our sleeves and uh our partnership is
going to definitely
um keep unfolding in in different ways
so we're excited we love love love being
creative together he's amazing I heard a
rumor about you that you are not a good
whistler is that true I am such a I like
of all the things to bring up yeah
because I did the musical The King and I
and you drew that song you know and I'm
like
I had to have a stunt Whistler that was
good though that's like the best I've
ever whistled in my life apparently I'm
good Under Pressure but no it was um oh
my gosh no I'm a terrible listener I I
can juggle I can hula hoop you can sing
obviously and then also um I don't know
if this is uh on the DL here yet or
apparently you're a good author
I mean there's there's a book in the
works at the moment as well um I mean
this is a moment in my life where I feel
like I've been through so many stressors
and challenges that a lot of people have
been through
Health romance finances family like you
name it you name I've ticked all these
boxes at this point and not every day is
perfect but I have shown myself how
resilient I can be and I do feel like
I'm not someone who guards my tools and
techniques like they're the national
secret right I like to share because
I've learned so much
about what you have to do and how you
have to think and
um to to keep going because life is hard
and life only got harder a couple of
years ago and so I I want to share kind
of my again like my insights if you will
and reference things that have happened
in my life and and anecdotes in my
career over all these decades so I mean
it's three and a half decades we've all
been together and I wanna I wanna share
ready to share you've got so many smiles
on people's faces and we're just so
grateful for you and thank you for
taking the time to come and I by the way
on that romance thing I think I know
someone Kindle who's single so like
I'm like me and my three dachshunds and
a movie at night and my career are like
that's the place I'm kind of in a really
happy space right now I mean eventually
they'll be open to it but right now I'm
good oh my God sorry Kendall you're out
I mean nothing personal it's just like a
just a space a happy space you can see
Demi Gibson on Friday Night episode of
secret celebrity home renovation at
eight right here on CBS we will be right
back